let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
hello kathy
barrett amanda forrest from facebook and
beard snick
here
debbie from salt lake is here matthew
from facebook jay jenny
velma from facebook
they're all here
they're all here
and
this morning we see that
maga the alt-right is gonna rebrand to
be the dark side
and the empire strikes back i
have these [ __ ] people ever watched a
movie before
dark maga really that's what you're
gonna rebrand is like oh we're nazis
that's
that's we're just gonna call ourselves
the empire the bad guys we're the
baddies
and we know it we're the baddies we're
the baddies holy actual [ __ ]
dark
manga
wow just paint yourselves as terrorists
this is gonna be easy folks i keep
telling you this i keep telling you if
we would pluck our head out of our
[ __ ] asses
democrats
liberals radical socialist moderates
generic ballot just anyone who doesn't
want a bunch of [ __ ] darth vaders
controlling our country
dark
maga
they're like oh we want revenge we want
revenge we're going to murder everyone
we're going to take your children we're
going to marry them we're going to make
sure women don't have any rights we're
going to ban books including the math
ones we don't even want you to have math
[ __ ]
dark manga holy actual [ __ ] this
we we shouldn't this this should be very
simple
the messaging is very easy
all
you know what
the generic ballot you know we hear
rachel bittikoffer our favorite
political strategist here dr rachel
bittikoffer always talks about the
generic ballot
do you know what the generic ballot does
in this country and i'm talking about
folks who generally aren't politically
engaged they don't know much about
politics
but they do vote even though they don't
know
they vote against [ __ ]
that's what they do
they vote against stuff
got it
so we gotta give them something to vote
against
now it's not really difficult to have
stuff to vote against these people are
setting the ball up on the tee
it's very easy
know why we can't see this
it's right there right there in front of
your eyes
it's not hard
to figure out
but we still run around going oh why
does dark manga why do the baddies
still have control
well
that's because we let them with our
messaging
we
let them
of course we see
there's no more mask mandates to protest
what the [ __ ] are they gonna protest by
the way
what are they going to protest
i mean you know i i think
killing the mass mandates on public
transportation is a little ridiculous
what's the big deal with having to wear
a mask in a confined space anyways for a
little bit of time
it's not hurting you and if it is get
the [ __ ] over it
but really at this point what are they
gonna protest what what are they gonna
protest
what are they gonna [ __ ] about
huh
what could it possibly be
i don't know i'm trying to figure it out
gas prices are going down
crude is going down the price
our unemployment's creeping towards
three percent
we have five million more positions open
than we have workers at this point
the economy's heated up the stock
market's higher than it's ever been
remember remember they used to do that
[ __ ] when the cheeto dust mobster
remember when the cheeto dust mobster
was the president he'd be like oh the
reason why he's so awesome is because
the stock market that's the only that's
the only
point of data that we need to prove that
the president is the most awesomest of
the awesome of the awesome ever in the
history of ever ever
was the stock market was so high
well here we are stock market's high the
economy's roaring
we just need to make sure in the 2022
midterm 2022 midterms that we do not
vote for people who are going to leave
more americans behind in the dust
because that's what they want to do they
want to tax the middle class
into oblivion
they want to make sure to take away your
safety net
they want to take away public education
from your children
i mean they're banning [ __ ] math
books in florida like literally they
don't want you to learn how to add and
do division
i mean they want division they just
don't want you to know how to do long
division
they want to marry your children they
want to sexualize your children's gender
they don't want women to have rights
next next up on the docket for women is
the right to vote
they i mean they took away their bodily
autonomy in these states and they're
really trying to tear down roe v wade so
the next the next goal
is to take away the access to the ballot
for women they're doing it with black
people in georgia trying to
in texas and all all the other
states that are in the cheeto
confederacy
that's what their plan is
so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do you're gonna sit at home with
the midterms
to make sure we have policies in place
with these this dark maga you're gonna
let dark
maga take over our country the dark side
that's what you want
you want the evil empire to take over
our country
they're saying the quiet part out loud
they're [ __ ] nazis
it really is
alarming
that george lucas basically modeled the
evil empire after nazi germany
the dark side as it were in the movie
and here they are
they're going to be dark manga like
they're branding themselves we're dark
maga now
we're on the dark side we're evil
and we're gonna we're gonna bang up
democracy go putin
what in the actual [ __ ] is going on
and we're having trouble we're having
trouble with messaging this is really
easy folks the messaging is so easy
it's so easy
and yes it's it's going to be hard to
win 2022 because we have to pluck the
heads out of everyone else's asses to
get them to realize
who the baddies are
because they're not sure the generic
ballot doesn't know they're more worried
about who's gonna win on the reality
show this week who's gonna win the
bachelor of the bachelorette who's gonna
win who's getting the rose who's going
to get voted off the island this week
who's who's catching touchdown passes
this week who traded who on this
basketball team
they're worried about that kind of [ __ ]
the generic ballot it is
so they'll go vote against stuff
so we have to give them something to
vote against
got it we have to we have to give them
something to vote against in our
messaging and it can't be us we can't be
like oh well
this democrat wants 18 minimum wage but
this one wants 17.50
so vote against the 117 that you're
voting against a democrat you got it do
you see how that works
you see how it works when you're voting
against a pro-democracy candidate stop
it
stop
we don't have to do that to ourselves we
don't have to divide ourselves and run
against each other we run against the
the dark side the evil empire
that is manga dark maga
ron desantis donald trump steve bannon
marjorie taylor [ __ ] green hoof foot
green
matt gatz
that child sex trafficker you see it's
so easy we have so many people to run
against
and we have so many people that they can
vote against the generic ballot we did
it in 2020.
do you think 81 million people voted for
joe biden hail to the no
there is plenty of that 81 million that
voted against
trumpism
in a maga hat trumpism
they voted against it
they didn't vote for something they
voted against something that's what we
have to do we have to get our messaging
straight so they have something to go
vote against
and they're giving us all the things we
need to vote against like they're
handing it up on a platter
just ask someone you know like that goes
you know a parent of you know maybe one
of your child's friends at school
just ask them this question did you hear
florida's trying to ban math books
they'd be like oh i didn't hear that
[ __ ]
i mean i know who won the reality show
last night but i didn't hear that that
that the nazis down in florida are
trying to ban math
they're trying to ban math
in florida they're trying to marry your
children in tennessee and missouri
they're sexualizing your children's
gender you're kindergarteners gender
they're sexualizing it
that's what they're doing
whoosh
ouch
everyone's here today cj is here from
facebook margie uh midas robin is here
mj is here stacy from facebook is
here janie is here mark from facebook is
here i don't know if i'm missing anybody
you guys i don't know if you guys know
this but holy moly we have a ton of new
listeners
a ton of new listeners here
on the tony michaels podcast we air
every single weekday monday through
friday on youtube twitter and twitch
just go to youtube and search the tony
michael's podcast our tony michaels
podcast you will find our channel
subscribe click the bell notification
you're not going to want to miss an
episode
even if you don't get to watch it live
no worries
it's always right there on the youtube
channel we are making
changes to where we cut clips the best
clips of the show to get to you also so
those will post there as well
and also
big news we're on the midas touch
facebook page airing live every single
weekday monday through friday so you can
catch us over there on facebook
two hours
every single day monday through friday
we are killing it for pro-democracy
folks out there i know you're sick and
tired you're probably sick and tired of
listening to the mainstream media
yammer on and on and on about dumb [ __ ]
that doesn't make any sense you know
your regulars chuck todd some of these
others
you're chuck todd types you're tired of
them giving the right wing
fair and balanced we got to let the
nazis on tv and get their fascist
opinion no we don't
you do not have to do that
what you need to do is get your
messaging correct
and yes the media is going to take them
a while to pluck their head out of their
ass too
well we'll work around that it is the
free press you got to give them time to
you know acclimate to a non-trump
society
mj says yay new listeners welcome to the
fam thanks for the super chat
mj
really appreciate it and and that is a
good point if you go over to the youtube
channel on the live chat
you can participate in the super chat
you need to do a super chat or a super
sticker
which might just lisa thank you for the
super sticker thank you very very much
we appreciate all the support you guys
show whether you retweet share like
uh whether you're subscribing
whatever whatever you're doing to
support the show we really do appreciate
it
if you're giving super sticker super
chats
you can do that you can also go download
every single episode on
apple spotify and google
it's over there on your favorite
directories make sure to leave us
a five star and a good review that
always helps out the show we do
appreciate it
when you do that uh kathy with this with
the super chat
she says second that mj
all the new listeners out there
and booyah boom shakalaka new listeners
it's growing every single day every
single day we're growing this show and
we're going to keep yelling and
screaming and giving you guys the
hard-hitting news with the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
and today we have some good trends we
have some good ones i'm going to talk
about we have of course we have dark
manga trending which i'm going to
probably rant two or three times about
today i'm sure
and then we have libs of tick tock do
you guys ever do you guys give or go to
twitter
and um and check out the
i don't i don't even know if it's up
anymore is it up anymore i i've been on
libs of tick tock
uh the the
the right wing
twitter account while you're over on
twitter follow us at tony michael's pod
follow the show at tonymichaelspotover
on twitter when you're over there and
you can follow me you can follow gabe as
well i'm at the tony michaels of course
on twitter and gabe is at i am gabe
sanchez speaking
of the great gabe sanchez i think he's
going to be joining us today for at the
bottom of the hour
for for a for a bit of time
before he has a hard out guy's busy over
there
he's busy over there making videos
coming up with ways to save our
democracy
with his talents
which that's what you guys should be
doing all you pro-democracy people out
there should be figuring out a way to
make sure not not just today not
tomorrow not next week next month
not a month before the midterms now now
is the time to start planning now is the
time to start pushing pro-democracy
ideas now is the time to start pushing
pro-democracy messaging and pound that
drum
and pound the drum and pound the drum
and pound the drum and make sure that
everyone you know and everyone you come
in contact with it is very very very
important that they participate
in this democracy and in this election
super
important
we cannot let down we cannot let up we
have to keep going and i'm not going to
every single weekday right here on
youtube twitter twitch and now the midas
touch facebook page noon eastern 11
central ninth pacific for two
hours
with the hard-hitting days news through
the trendy trends and the tweety tweets
well all these comments rolling in paula
says yes fox news is trash tv i call it
traitor tv here um thank you for the
comment paula
um we got a lot of people new people in
here
a lot of new people welcome welcome
welcome everybody
from facebook from youtube from twitter
libs of tick tock is trending i've been
on lids of tick tock the twitter account
that is um you know it's a right wing
account i guess i guess the um i guess
someone outed and journalists outed the
person who who started the libs of tick
tock who got libs of dick doc going i
guess i don't know i don't know
and they're pissed off about it
how you doxed me get the [ __ ] out of
here
the account that exposes people is is is
upset that they're exposed
[ __ ] snowflakes anita says sparklers
yeah we have we have how how spark
sparklers here too that come and watch
the show welcome to all the sparklers
the minus mighty the sparklers the
[ __ ] fam
as mj likes to call him mj loves
to call it the [ __ ] fam we are the
[ __ ] fam here
and we welcome all those who are
pro-democracy to participate
in it
and to say [ __ ] them when we need to say
[ __ ] them
so let's let's get into the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends while we uh
we wait for uh gabe
gabe sanchez the great great gabe
sanchez to get here um let's go to break
after we come back right after this
we'll get into the tweety tweets and the
trend trends don't go anywhere we'll be
back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome
welcome back to the show thanks for
hanging through the break you guys still
like that video the trucker convoy i
love that dude i think i need to put
part two
on a commercial what do you guys think
it's on the youtube channel if you want
to go over and subscribe to the youtube
channel you can subscribe
just to search on youtube
at
toni michael the tony michaels or the
tony michaels podcast
on on youtube and you can see
letters from a trucker convoy one and
part two maybe i'll put part two and
start playing that in commercial
everyone likes the trucker even though
the trucker convoys tucked its tail
between its leg and ran on and then greg
abbott decided to have a trucker convoy
town in mexico really hurt the
texas economy that's a real smart thing
for a governor to do herded state
economy on purpose to try to blame it on
a democrat these [ __ ] idiots
these [ __ ] idiots
you'd see what i mean by this shouldn't
be that goddamn hard
to beat these sons of [ __ ]
greg abbott had to [ __ ] had to
cocktail and run
on his plan to stop up the border
he had to he didn't have a [ __ ]
choice
because they were going to blame it on
him because it was his [ __ ] fault
because truckers are like what in the
[ __ ] are you doing man you're hurting
our industry
intentionally just just to own the libs
let's cost private businesses hundreds
of millions of dollars to own the libs
okay yeah good job it's kind of like tan
in your nut sack to own the libs
what in the [ __ ] are these people doing
what are you what are you doing
tanning your nut sack
so that way you can prevent low t
because low t makes you gay or some [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
trying to say
you
you try to figure it out
we try every goddamn day here to try to
figure out what these people are doing
and where they're going with this but
it's hard to tell
this dark manga [ __ ]
it's absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
here we are here we are with the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
so let's get to it let's get to let's
get to the news
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the part of the show where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
journey trends the part that you love
the most
because i'm the hostess with the mostest
we should have our co-host here in just
a few minutes but let's see let's see if
we can round up some [ __ ] before he gets
here you know that's what the [ __ ] list
roundup is everyone's like what's the
[ __ ] list tony
you know sometimes there's good things
trending and they're like oh why'd you
put that on the [ __ ] list that's a good
thing i'm like well right but
twitter is the [ __ ] list like the
trending list on twitter here let me
show you
let me make this bigger for all you
listening out there on the directories
you guys really should at least come
subscribe to the youtube channel
to watch a few episodes
that way you can see
how we're surfing through twitter this
is see you go to the the little hashtag
here the trends and then there's a
little tab here trending
and then it's got one two three you know
it's got them in order like right now
libs of tick tock is trending at number
three uh dark maga is trending at number
four
you see here you see in here three and
four
dark
by the way the people who are so upset
that libs of tick-tock have been outed
they've been doxxed which is that's not
what doxing is but whatever
is is dark manga they're mad
they're mad that you exposed
them and you now cancel them and we're
not for cancel cancel the people who
canceled them i don't know
again if you're trying to keep up and
you're trying to make sense of these
[ __ ] good [ __ ] luck i mean
we try to do it every day here every day
we try to make sense of these boneheads
but it gets really difficult and is a
stretch to figure out what these people
are thinking and why they're thinking
this way
holy moly
so several things trending here let's go
back to the uh the timeline
let's see if we got some let's see if we
got some good stuff on the timeline
oh nate silver was trending earlier
i don't know if you guys know this nate
silver was trending earlier here here's
his uh here's his tweet the average
and let me see if i can do it doesn't he
the average american spends something
like five hours per year on a plane
the mass mandate might be good or bad at
the margin
but it is very unlikely to make a major
difference in the overall course
of coronavirus this would be true
this would be true if airplanes didn't
travel you dumb [ __ ] nate silva
really is a bonehead the other thing too
is he says uh average americans spend
five hours per year on a plane
this decision just didn't affect trains
you [ __ ] bonehead nate silver really
is a [ __ ]
he is such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
how we ever consider this guy to be
smart and intelligent is beyond me
here's what i said i said the average
american spends like
five seconds per year listening to nate
silver
his account might be good or bad at the
margin
but it is very unlikely to make a major
difference in the overall course of the
[ __ ]
he is such a dumb [ __ ] let's go tell him
that his tweets sucked
there we go type it in here your tweet
sucks nate
it really does it's really stupid
yes yes twitter i want to tweet the word
sucks they don't like the word sucks
it's not about the you see this tweet
here
so so twitter gets all pissed off here
about this uh this this response this
reply that i put in the um in the tweets
when the tweet
sucks you see here um i have the
shitless roundup but we have it in the
other tweet
and they don't they don't knock it so it
has to be your tweet sucks that's what
they hate about this
they're like you sure you want to tweet
this tony you sure you want to tweet
your tweets yeah i do because his
[ __ ] tweet sucks nate silver's tweet
sucks someone says who's nate
[Laughter]
exactly regina says who's nate
who the [ __ ] is nate silver yeah [ __ ]
that guy
um so um
you want to hate on him i i also tweeted
earlier uh dark maga doesn't know
they're the baddies
like they did they have no clue
dark manga has no clue that they're the
bad guys
like they don't even see the [ __ ]
[ __ ] where you're like oh
oh you mean the dark side like on star
wars like that's what that's what you
are
that's that's what you are
uh
a golf
twitter slayer here says b block 29 says
if you don't have to wear a mask on a
flight to protect if you don't have to
wear a mask on a flight to protect me i
don't have to pee in a toilet to protect
you
i think she's i think she's saying um
you know you're not making any sense i
mean the mask isn't just to protect the
person wearing it is to protect the
people around them now here's what i
will say
here's what i will say about the
mandates um it's not it's not uh
politically you know for the virus it's
it might be pretty bad especially if we
have a new variant right
uh and and also for people who are
predisposed even if they're vaccinated
or they can't get vaccinated
from being in the cabin of an airplane i
don't see that it's such a big deal
that we continue to wear mask on public
transportation it's not hurting anyone
like you're not suffering i i took an
amtrak train
last summer
and we had to wear masks the entire time
we were on the train i mean other than
when you're eating or drinking right
and really honestly it
wasn't that bad i mean you could breathe
and you were you were fine yeah i didn't
i didn't you know it wasn't like
i got indoctrinated into liberal radical
socialist ideas because my had my mask
on
i just wasn't getting people sick and
other people weren't getting me sick was
kind of the point
so it really is not that big of a deal
but here's the thing
is if this is the way it's gonna be
right because this seems the way it's
gonna be that this mandate's going to be
struck down
if
if the mandate struck down if that's the
case if that's the what the
what our reality is going to be then
what we should start doing is start
questioning what they're protesting what
are you protesting with kovid
like why are you still protesting why
are you pro why are you yelling and
screaming
and calling and calling people who
believed in science and medical
and
believed in medical experts what are you
still yelling screaming that we're
fascist for
there are no mandates no vaccine
mandates no mass mandates they're all
gone
all the mandates that biden put on are
poof gone they don't exist so what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
the fascism in this country is happening
in these states
where they're trying to out florida
florida i mean florida's even banned in
math they're banning division even
though that's what they do is division
they're banning long division in schools
um
libs of tick tock is trending
because the
the words libs of tick tock but it's an
actual um
twitter account
so what libs of tic toc how they started
is they would go over to
tick tock and they would pull liberals
videos off tic tac that they thought
were cringe or something and a lot of
them were cringe right
my videos ended up on lips at dick duck
several times it's beautiful
oh i love to be on libs of tick tock
there's no better badge of honor than
for my tic toc video to end up on libs
of dick duck
because they [ __ ] hate me
i love that you i i love that that the
followers of lib libs of tick tock
[ __ ] hate my guts i love it
that's exactly what i want i want to
piss them off
that's who that's who i'm here for is to
piss them i mean i'm here to give you
a cathartic outlet
and and to provide you some some
messaging that has some strategic
outrage that you can direct to make sure
we win
2022 so democrats can deliver
in our democracy as opposed to
republicans trying to destroy it with
dark maga
but i've been on libs of dick duck i
tweeted
does that mean i'm famous i don't think
i don't think that means i'm famous i
think that just means i made some cringe
ass videos which some of my videos are
cringe i'll admit it that was the whole
point
to end up you know the cringy ones end
up on lids and tick tock to piss them
off
oh okay let's go to the tweety tweets
and trendy trends our co-host should be
joining us any minute now
any minute now he should be joining us
he might even be listening he's just
waiting just waiting for his opportunity
to come in uh trending lives of tick
tock dark manga we'll go through that
with uh with gabe here let's see if we
can find another topic in the meantime
taco tuesday it is tuesday anyone else
make tacos out there on tuesday we make
tacos not every single tuesday but a lot
on tuesday
you know and it's not like real tacos
it's like we just
brown some hamburger put the seasoning
in throw some cheese in the hamburger on
like a tortilla
that's that's our taco tuesday normally
sometimes we go there's a really good um
there's a really good mexican restaurant
down the street that we go to every once
in a while and it's really good to go
there for tacos
sometimes
we even do the whole thing
where you go to the non-taco taco
tuesday place taco bell a lot of you're
like taco bell isn't tacos maybe we
should ask gabe he's a taco
and burrito connoisseur he has it on his
twitter
he even said have you guys seen the uh
interview with uh gabe on bad brad
berkwich show you guys should go watch
that show um he even says on there that
his favorite food and me and him have
talked about it privately
he loves tacos he loves tacos
so maybe we should ask him maybe the
question is is taco bell
his taco bell taco since he's a taco and
burrito connoisseur
maybe we should ask him uh oklahoma city
is trending
it's trending because
uh it is the anniversary april 19th is
the anniversary
of the oklahoma
city bombing
um where
timothy mcveigh
used an explosive device to kill
to kill americans
because he hated the american government
and he wanted to tear down democracy
sound familiar
sound familiar
i think it is
um
we should not look away we should not
forget the event that happened
at oklahoma city and the bombing that
happened there and the extremism that
was bred
to cause it
and we're seeing that now that's what
dark manga is
dark magga
would drive
a truck full of explosives next to a
federal building to kill other americans
because they hate democracy
because democracy delivers things like
equality
democracy delivers things like equity
now it's not perfect democracy is not
perfect it never will be it's tough
democracy is [ __ ] hard folks that's
why that's why all these bone hints love
authoritarianism
it's so easy to pick out the person
who who will press the people you want
them to oppress right it's so easy to
pick out donald trump
and say well he'll oppress the people i
want to be oppressed and he won't
oppress me
and and my life will be great because of
it right that's the [ __ ] stupid-ass
[ __ ]
that we have to deal with in this
country
the authoritarianism that's why they do
that
because democracy is difficult it's
[ __ ] difficult to get people to go
vote
and especially the vote the way that
they should in their own interest it
really is difficult it's not easy
i mean we can do it
we can do it
we can definitely do
the whole democracy thing
we just have to stay focused get our
messaging right pluck our heads out of
our asses because see that's a problem
sometimes that we have is to pluck our
own heads out of our own ass
and to realize that sometimes we have to
speak to people in a certain way to get
them motivated to go vote
and to vote for pro-democracy they did
it in 2020
i've told you over and over and over
again i do not believe that 81 million
people voted for joe biden
i believe that there is a very large
handful of those people
that voted against trump oh we got our
we got our co-host available here is he
is he ready is he ready we got a
question for you gabe did you hear the
question gabe did you hear the question
that we know i didn't hear the question
what was that today today is taco
tuesday and we got and you are a taco
and burrito connoisseur right yep that
is true
um even on the the interview that you
did with bad bread you said your fa
because you asked what your favorite
food was right and you you i i don't
know exactly how you said it but you
said um
you know i guess it was stereotypically
you're you like tacos yeah i i was like
i'm mexican you know right spanish like
you know not to fill the stereotype but
but i could probably do tacos every day
every single day now there's
like breakfast because there's like so
much you can do with tacos right you
could do different toppings different
different meats do not means you just
want to do veggies you could do
breakfast tacos right i mean you could
have tacos at any point during that you
can make a breakfast tacos and just that
that's just a normal taco you can have
it during lunch that's your lunch taco
dinner taco they're always good i don't
know if the new listeners know this but
you also you you you you talk more
highly of tacos than you do even of your
your uh well it's probably about
sodastream
so like but here's the question that i
want to i want to ask you right and
maybe you can you know sort this out for
us
is taco bell tacos no that
why
why is it not tacos
but if you can put anything in tacos if
you literally can do anything with taco
escape why is it talking about sure here
you could do fine you could do anything
with tacos
taco bell you could theoretically you
could put anything in
a tortilla and call it and
i
look at taco bell and sure i think at
the bare minimum
it meets taco standards right but it's
not a real taco like
i mean they're not my favorite tacos but
right i mean they're i don't i mean
there might be people who they're their
favorite tacos but for me i would say uh
for me a little george han reference
there you go there you go uh for me uh
tacos are you know it's not taco bell
but here's the thing
uh the reason i say that is because the
standard taco you get from taco bell is
just kind of ground meat with taco
seasoning on it you know hey
it's that's that's what we do when i
make tacos and buy houses right you know
i'm sorry you're not making tacos
uh they sell other ones
they're white people tacos right right
right right yeah midwest midwest you've
never actually had real mexican food
exactly yeah yeah totally totally fine
maybe i should look some up on yelp and
i should send you some addresses and get
hey go check these out in your area
well here's the thing we actually have a
mexican restaurant just down the street
and they yeah there is we go there every
once in a while on tuesday sometimes you
know other days but you know if we don't
want to make tacos that day or if we're
just not feeling the whole taco bell
thing which
a lot of times you feel the taco bell
after you eat it not before you eat it
right that's sometimes a problem with
taco bell but we do we do go uh down the
street there's a great there's a great
place that we go oh that's good and they
they yeah they got a great local
yeah yeah it's it's great food it's
great food down there so anyway for me
uh i would say that taco bell is not uh
i wouldn't call that a taco but you know
that's
right
do you have do you eat taco bell often
no have you ever have you ever uh i've
had taco bell
three times in my life three wait wait
wait a second so you've only ate taco
bell three times in your life and you're
gonna i've had it because
i've had tacos
and i've had del taco twice
del taco is a west coast you're right
it's like the west coast taco bell right
right yeah right right i mean there are
taco bells on the west coast though
right right no they definitely are but
uh for the people who are listening who
might be not on the west coast uh del
taco's out here but yeah i mean like
yeah so so to settle a little bit of the
debate here because if taco bell and del
taco aren't tacos
what is the greatest place on earth
and i'm talking about a restaurant that
people could go to what is the greatest
place that you have found
the best tacos that you effect because i
know you go all sorts of different
places right like i was going to say i
go to mexico and you can get some great
apple store tacos but obviously that's
not accessible just to certain people
but uh
what is it if you're if you're gonna be
somewhere if you had to choose like
if someone's like look you get to choose
this is your last time to eat tacos gabe
your last time on ever
to eat tacos
and you get to choose any place you want
to eat tacos you have to buy them in
mexico city
so mexico city and what's my place
called what's the place called oh
i'd have to look it up it's like a it's
like a small street vendor it's
literally a hole in the wall so it's
like a cart or what uh they've got an
outside cart with the grill but they
like where they've also got the alpaca
store and they're just chopping it off
and then they like cut off a little
slice of pineapple uh
but
the spot i'm trying i think i'm almost
positive it was covered in
um taco crumbs like you don't have to
know the name of this place you just
remember yeah i know exactly where it is
yeah there's another spot i went to that
my cousin took me to
that they literally um
it's like a it's like a a like a
drive-in diner style thing where they
bring the tacos to you so it's like it's
like the sonic of tacos kind of exactly
but it's very very good right right
right but yeah if i had to go um
because there were some new spots i
discovered i went i went in october uh
to mexico city and uh found some new new
spots that were good but i mean like if
you had to travel in the u.s i would say
uh burritos in san francisco are pretty
good they've got their own style mission
burrito
tacos are are good but in la
la is and san diego as well um like san
diego is really known for fish tacos and
other like kind of the seafood style
tacos
um
and then la has really good
taco trucks and taco carts and like set
up on the sidewalk and you got to follow
him around kind of thing though yeah
lying around the corner outside of a
target and you're on the sidewalk
outside just waiting like really good
vampiro tacos like oh it's so good
well i'm glad we settled this debate
because i still think that taco bell is
is technically tacos
to me to me to me sure to me in my
non-cultured
i'm also not
a big fan of hard shell like the
hardshell heart she'll let you get it
like taco bell here's here's what i'll
tell you guys to do hard shell-esque
okay
that's not the way that i would i will
tell you the dorito taco [ __ ] that's not
tacos that that's oh that's a step too
far
that's a step too far the dorito taco
thing yeah i'm glad i'm glad we settled
this debate and you know we do the hard
pressing issues here oh yeah i'm joining
you today is taco tuesday and right now
now i'm thinking
where are you going tonight all right
okay so you're going to search down a
truck then huh yeah yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna look it up i'm gonna
find it there is a good spot i have
around the corner from us where we live
uh
that is like a
it's like a solid go-to spot there's
other areas in boyle heights that are so
good that i've yet to discover in l.a um
but yeah i uh i have a running
running list of places to go but i still
have not gone do you have an app is
there an app on your phone i wish there
was an app like a taco app like a toggle
yeah hey
don't say it out loud that's i'm gonna
[ __ ] do it okay well i i want to go
back to the tweety tweets and journey
drinks here yeah yeah because i want to
ask you because i've been on the lives
of tick tock account before have you
ever have you ever been on the libs of
tic-tac account like myself
well i mean you're tick-tocked you got
right right you know famous
famous sticker yeah i
i
i don't i don't think i have or at least
to the extent that
i haven't ever been tagged or no one's
ever like spotted me out
so i would have no idea i wouldn't be
surprised if i was on there making some
case for why
hypocrites uh are with you know our
republicans or hypocrites or uh they you
know they they can't pick a lane or
whatever the topic might be so i
wouldn't be surprised if i was actually
on there i just don't know if i'm
actually there
uh i feel like the only ones that you
really know about is like when you get
like the defiant l's uh post or
something and then you get a bunch of
like yeah yeah yeah i've been there too
right i've had andy i've have andy no
trolls after me too
oh those are great people yeah well yeah
and by great i mean terrible people
right the andy no nazis they're
fantastic you know they're more they're
not quite dark manga but they're kind of
close right no andy nazis oh yeah andy
nazis uh thank you lisa um
she says minus ken for bonehead of the
church this is like an ongoing thing i
feel like you know i'd have to have a
pull just between the two of them i know
we'll see who wins between lisa and ken
thank you lisa for the
for the super chat um
taylor uh i i think as lorenz is that is
that you say it yeah
he's a writer for uh the washington post
and this is why it's trending apparently
she wrote an article that exposed the
the woman who's behind the libs of tic
tac i actually tried to go this morning
and find that account i don't know that
that account exists anymore did it get
banned or something uh well i know in
the last week lifts of tick tock has
gone through a bunch of reporting
um
just i mean here's the thing
they do have posts that are just not
good
uh right they take content from tick
tock and post it on there in an attempt
to own someone now technically
you're
using a video against someone's
uh
permission especially if it's used in
that wave so
um
well but that's only if that's only if
it's not downloadable because if you
because you can set your tic tac i used
to set my tick tock account where you
couldn't download the videos right i
haven't done that anymore because people
they they still like screen grab them
and they rip them you know whatever so i
just like i just let them down uh yeah
do you want to go to the account the
account still exists i think it's being
yeah give me that give me the uh give me
the link if you've got it yeah um but um
um taylor here wrote the article she
said libs of tick tock has become a
powerful force online shaping right-wing
media impacting anti-lgbtq legislation
and influencing millions by posting
viral videos aimed at inciting outrage
i wrote about the account the one behind
it and why it matters so you can go to
the washington post if you subscribe
actually i think washington post lets
you read like one or two articles a
month so if you're not at your one or
two article uh there also may or may not
be a plug-in for different browsers that
allow you oh okay
paywalls i'm not saying that you should
use it but if you were to google
something
what would you what would you google
what would you google if you were
if you have a person was going to do
something right you might say like
bypass paywall
um uh-huh but so bypass paper
and then like enter in the browser users
oh okay like chrome oh okay yeah so buy
this paywall for chrome right then there
may be a github uh url oh okay that you
go to and i mean we're saying you should
use it yeah i'm not saying you should
use it i'm just saying like
yeah i'm just saying you're not a
sponsored voice yeah yeah you should
definitely not
do that yeah yeah okay yeah good um so
so taylor here has um what they're
calling doxing which is not doxxing we
actually went through this with an
interview that we had with uh
that
is it is it that guy donish is that his
account i can i always forget uh
i think it's uh
that
guy guy that danish guy yep so donish um
he actually came on the show and talked
about boxing with us that was back in
december i believe um
yeah it was a while away and this is not
doxing this is not doxing by the way
right no this is not doxing right this
is investigative journalism it's not
like there is here's the thing the way
that they got this information they
weren't hacking they didn't go into
anyone's private information they got
this information from public areas
online
the registrar through the not to be
confused public areas not to be confused
with your test testicles that you're
that you're right not yet well those are
privates but oh okay you did tucker
carlson they very much become public
i just want to make sure yeah not to be
confused with publix the uh market right
the supermarket in in florida and right
the one with desantis but right uh
the um
uh it's not doxing right oh holy [ __ ]
you gotta see this this is why i
couldn't find it you're blocked i'm
living tick tock wait
block me what happened to first
amendment baby i don't know i mean
they're really pissed off that they're
you know being outed and canceled or
whatever but they canceled me they
blocked me
right why am i blocked that
you know what if you need to take a few
and go cried out you know with your beta
self yeah i'm sure that they would love
that that's probably what i i should go
tan my balls for a little while to gain
my to gain my man strength back so i'm
not so upset um
i actually i actually see this as a as a
badge of honor right like yeah no yeah
if you get i mean i've been blocked by
random people i've never encountered
with but because of something i may have
tweeted that did not tag them or via
association to someone else
uh i
am like oh who's this and then i click
it and then it goes you can't view it
because you're blocked and i'm like i've
never like uh
who's the guy that's always at cpac um
uh he's got like goatee not not not
miller um
oh are you talking are you talking about
the um the the the guy who did get her
no no that's that's miller that's the
other miller oh uh
uh gortzka uh oh oh sebastian gorka yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he has me blocked oh
really on twitter and i have literally
never
tweeted
about him that i know of well it's
probably a list it probably a list that
he found no no you just started blocking
all these people are gonna make fun of
me so i'd better block them what's i
would imagine that this block from libs
a tick tock i'd imagine it's because
that they um posted a video of me and
then i probably like quote tweeted or
something right like i wasn't yeah like
i went like oh i got him i'm live is a
tick-tock oh no oh cause i'm like i i
don't give a [ __ ] about the trolls like
right i welcome the trolls i want the
girls now i don't want them saying
racist bigoted [ __ ] in the comments like
in our chat but i welcome the trolls i
want them to come and listen to me i
want them to figure out you know what
the hell i'm about yeah but so the the
libs of tic toc uh banning me isn't
surprising because i think i ended up
there i don't know it was probably three
or four times that people pointed out i
actually didn't follow the account and i
don't think they tagged the people um
you know someone has to see it and then
um you know
point it out to you right
but my my tick tock handle
is the same as my twitter handle at b
tony michaels so on the tick tock video
that they would rip because at the time
they would have to rip it
so they spent the time to record the
screen like the whole video yeah that's
how much they have to indoctrinate
themselves yes well that's the thing
that i loved and i think that's probably
what i said i don't know i have to go
back and search to find but that's
probably what i said i probably said i
don't allow people to download my tic
tac so you had to actually watch this
video yep to that not just to see what
it was about to just to download it
or to rip it just to post it on twitter
so i'm very satisfied with what you did
yeah i called it w yeah it's a good one
it's a good one i think they did it
several times and that's probably why um
that's probably why they had me blocked
i would imagine but to answer the
original question no none of this is
doxxing like i've worked with uh i've
worked on a few of
similar let's say not not similar in the
sense of like lips or tick tock stuff
but like for other people that have done
pretty egregious racist bigoted things
in public and they put themselves out
there and then obviously after the fact
they're like oh i got cancelled it's
like no
you did this to yourself
uh i've worked on a few different ones
help research i don't i will say this
i've worked in the background on a few
of these things i don't like to be the
center of attention to be like oh i've
identified this person that's not my
thing i don't need to bring in that type
of attention to
uh my account or like my kind of
personality brand whatever right but i
will help in terms of researching uh and
it's you know there are different
methods to do it i won't reveal what
those methods are obviously um but it
has nothing to do with hacking look at
look at you being all spyish and
secretive all says this the people that
are afraid and get all butt hurt about
like getting their information or
getting themselves discovered online
it is all things that they have posted
online right through various different
profiles they don't have to be the same
name or they use an email here that's
registered to this thing all publicly
accessible stuff
they put out there but it's also it's
also like through
like um you know if you if you find
someone on facebook and they don't
really have a lot of stuff posted but
they have their family members posted to
their family there's a ton of different
things i can have on there like oh i use
the account here but my account is
actually connected this other account
and that account has my email shown
let's say that you
had it on youtube and you're like oh
this this twitter account actually
connects this youtube account right and
i now see your face right and there's
ways of you know
looking for that there's also your
emails is attached to the account so you
can see what the email is so there's
ways that people
can uh
you know
reveal themselves in a in a in an uh
in a way that they aren't like really
sure right so it's not really
documenting it no no you're not careless
you're mining you're mining the internet
that which anyone could do right again
all the things that they put out there
right this is publicly accessible again
no one is hacking no one is is accessing
private information this is all stuff
that these boneheads
have put out there
and have revealed themselves they
thought it was they thought it was
nothing they thought it was hidden
whatever and if you just do a simple
google search or on twitter or youtube
or something you'd be surprised what you
could find you know depending on how
also how unique your name is or you know
a
the profession you're in like you know
wouldn't be surprised oh i found uh i
found you on linkedin right you know
whatever and that's that's the other
thing too that i was just about to say
is like the linkedin thing when you go
on linkedin because like you're tying it
to your work like that's the whole point
of linkedin is like where you work and
then when you do that it like
you know you're just automatically
saying hey look at me i've got a job
here's my job and if i'm being racist in
public right it you know it really is
dumb stuff i want to go back to what uh
right wing cope says here about the
lives of tick tock thing real quick
um i think i think right wing code
points us out very well here lives of
tick tock is a proud defender of
groenman having sex with oh yeah i
remember we're still in middle school
unsurprisingly her entire narrative
about teachers grooming kids is massive
projection yep um this is about milo
unopolis i don't know if people know
this he kind of he used to be
sort of suitable pseudo famous for being
he was yeah he was a big
anti-lgbt guy or something with
breitbart um
he had his big personality he actually
he tried to write a book and then um
believe it or not bill maher had him on
his show and everyone was really [ __ ]
pissed off that bill maher had him on
the show and bill maher said this he
said sunlight is the best disinfectant
which i agree with i agree with and
after that interview after he went on
bill maher and bill maher basically
exposed him to a
broader audience people were like whoa
this guy's really [ __ ] gross this guy
is despicable he's vile and he lost his
book deal and he lost his position at
breitbart i mean it basically destroyed
it yeah i mean he said some crazy stuff
like there was a he took a photo and i
don't know if he was like kind of
goading people to respond but he did
have a photo where it was like a syringe
and also
uh
was it liquid over mctin or what was it
it was he he just did a new job he's a
[ __ ] he's also got his like
conversion therapy right well and that's
down in florida which is not surprising
in nazi florida
he's trying to start conversion therapy
centers but here here libs a tick tock
this woman who started this account said
milo yiannopoulos didn't say anything
wrong are people seriously arguing that
you're not ready for sex under 16 um
that was all a distraction the lgbt
propaganda agenda is much more of a
threat to the minds of children
so basically pedophiles
pedophiles aren't a threat it's it's the
lgbt community because
they prefer their same gender of the
person they love this is really [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] right this is again this is
again the same dark maga the the the
evil empire that wants to take over our
country they're sexualizing this woman
who has a lip is a tick tock is
sexualizing children's gender they're
sexualizing it they're sexualizing their
their preference of who they love like
look
just because you may or may not be gay
doesn't mean you can't fall in love with
someone else right this is all [ __ ]
nonsense and [ __ ] and this is the
[ __ ] that they used milo for because he
was openly gay i think he was actually
married wasn't he or was he just engaged
uh
he had a
uh
a boyfriend yeah well i i can't remember
if they were if they were actually
engaged or they were married or get
married like there was a narrative there
right but i can't remember right also
the big thing the big thing for him was
that he was married to uh a black guy
and he was using that as a i'm not
racist right i'm not racist but i work
for breitbart and i write this pretty
defamatory stuff around like just like
just crazy insane stuff
uh
for
oh i just retweeted the wrong one i
really tweeted rick wilson you're you're
arch enemy oh boy uh oh
we'll we'll read rick's tweet since i
retweeted it just for you go ahead but
yeah uh let's see if i'm just quickly
looking at
uh his wikipedia to see if there's
anything about that but yeah i remember
that because it was brought up during
his interview with
yeah
bill maher because it was kind of like
well i can't be anti-gay because i am
i'm just an anti-gay it's like really
weird it was a you could be in a group
and you could still be self-hating like
the two rights can be it's kind of the
candace owens effect right right it's
kind of the same [ __ ] that christian
walker candace owns and and really it's
the maga effect because really manga is
against themselves like they're against
their own self-interest they're against
what they're actually saying like oh we
want better jobs like yeah but you're
voting in people who are doing away with
the good jobs uh rick wilson i'll read
this tweet here gabe's arch nemesis here
um old and busted faux out full rage
over us laughing at tucker's
testicle tanning that's good tucker's
testicle tanning new hotness faux rage
over libs of tick tock being outed it
really is stupid yeah it really is so
well i mean yeah you look you look at
this and it's like
they have nothing to talk about right
you ask you ask anyone on the right and
you say hey
if you don't want like here
you talk about something they go oh you
took it out of context that's not what
we meant right
you guys are focused on something that
clearly tucker carlson he goaded you
guys into talking about it and
this and that right she's like okay fine
so what are the important topics oh well
we got to talk about border security or
we got to talk about you know jobs or
this and that is like okay well you know
let's talk about those things what is
the solution right like yesterday
everyone you had uh ted cruz bridget
gabriel a ton of people that were like
um
uh a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads it
sounds like right no yeah yeah they're
they they only had one thing that said
um
abolish
the irs oh okay
so
obviously because you know ted cruz
makes sense
yeah well you know tea party boy and uh
you look at these people and you say
okay fine you have this claim right
abolish abolish the irs
what's the alternative right what is the
solution if they aren't the ones that
are going to be actually processing and
doing the accounting and analyzing to
make sure that no one's taking advantage
of the system like many have not gonna
point to fingers but definitely trump
rich
right rich people you know uh you know
the what the top one of one percent you
know uh you look at that that's bernie
by the way
that's that's all i can do you know okay
okay just a bunch of just that one line
just that one just that one isn't that
good yeah uh but but you you look at
this and you say well what's the
alternative okay what do you what are
you offering what do you what are you
providing as a solution and it is
never
uh never provided anything there is
never a follow-up you know it there's
never anything that they say like hey i
have this viewpoint and i think we
should get rid of this thing but as a
result i feel like this is the way that
it should be or this is the way that we
should do it right there's like nothing
they give you as an alternative to say
like okay well let's let's discuss it
how would that work right it's just like
get rid of it and then you're like
but the thing is is they have no real
policy and even this abolish the irs
they're not serious because
essentially what they're saying is
abolish the irs and start the tax
department like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right because they want to
tax the middle class they want to tax
the [ __ ] out of the middle class and the
reason why is so they don't have to tax
rich people because that that's where
we're headed like uh hey we're gonna
have to start taxing you know like the
elon musk of the world we should tackle
god forbid
the billionaires that are just hoarding
money yeah right
it's like we've already had 50 years to
review uh you know uh an uh have
analysis of trickle-down economics or or
like 40 years or so of the trick
trickle-down economics where we had
papers that have come out that have
literally said look if you want to run
your economy and set it up this way and
like try to stimulate growth and
prosperity it's not going to work
because what ends up happening is the
rich people say oh [ __ ] i get i get tax
incentives and i don't have to pay this
much money okay okay yeah i'll give it
i'll give it to the people below me and
they just hoard it away and they put it
in their vault and they're you know you
got
huge huge vaults of coins that are
swimming through like mcduck you know
and all this stuff
and uh scrooge mcduck yeah
and you're like oh hey why don't you uh
why don't you give back right right it's
the same it's the same thing when the
government said hey we're gonna help
airlines out we're gonna bail you guys
out now there's a condition you got to
use this money and reinvest it into your
companies don't do stock buybacks don't
give any like uh golden handcuff you
know parachutes all this stuff don't
don't uh don't reward the people that
got you in the situation and they go
okay okay meanwhile they're like behind
their back their fingers are crossed you
know like toes and all fingers are
crossed and then all of a sudden you
look during the pandemic and they're
like oh we have to lay people off we got
to do this and like what happens to the
billions of dollars we gave you
previously we told you to invest it
right would you reinvest that capital
like what what what's going on and
they're like oh well
we felt like we had to
we did a really hard job of running this
company so we felt like we had to give
ourselves more money and when our stock
went down
we thought it would be a good idea to
reinvest by buying more stock
in our own company using the money that
you gave us
so
stuff like that where i say i'm like
you're always gonna have these bad
actors and a lot of the time the bad
actors are the rich people because the
rich people think of course
never gonna get caught and if i am
caught i've got money to pay for lawyers
and money will buy this off and pay for
this and unfortunately it very much is
it's a class uh type of war that's
happening
and republicans are the ones who are
feeding that
by providing the tools
and benefits to the rich who
who don't want to don't want to give
back don't want to contribute don't feel
like paying someone a fair wage
or a livable income
is the right thing to do as opposed to
them who have lavishly
billions of dollars and they could not
spend it quick enough where you've got
billionaires
like uh
like uh jeff bezos who has to build a
dick rocket just to go
get hard i don't know
like base space dildo okay space dildo
speaking of tax day i've seen this video
um and we're probably gonna get dings so
we're probably gonna have to mute this
on youtube but i want to play it anyways
um it is a it is a jerry seinfeld clip
it says happy tax day um speaking of
write-offs that you were saying rattles
this is what reminded me
but you were supposed to get me a refund
you can't get a refund your warranty
expired two years ago
so we're gonna make the post office pay
for my new stereo now it's a write-off
for them how is it a write-off they just
write it off
write it off what jerry all these big
companies they write off everything
you don't even know what a write-off is
do you
no i don't
but they do
and they're the ones writing it off
it just it just reminded me since
yesterday was tax day uh and and you
were talking about write-offs and big
companies um because you know
essentially i i think what you're saying
is is that
uh someone like elon musk because yes he
owns companies but his actual personal
wealth we could tax him in the oblivion
and the guy would still be worth
billions of dollars like he could still
have a space dildos he could still do
the things he wants and he would still
[ __ ] about being taxed too much um no
matter how much we taxed him whether it
was one dollar or a gazillion so
i do want to go to back to the trendy
trends
the other the other thing that i want to
say is how
uh
people like mackenzie scott right
bezos's uh ex-wife
cannot spend the money
fast enough
she will literally donate them in like
to to her credit she's doing a great job
she is donating the money she's giving
the money away giving it to programs and
that would benefit from such uh you know
in a massive wealth uh and then what
ends up happening is you know she's got
stock in in amazon
and that [ __ ]
skyrocketed right there was a 2021 she
gave away billions of dollars and in the
same week she made that money back
on just the amazon stock that she had
she sold the stock
took the billions gave it to charities
gave it to programs organizations and
then by the end of the week she was back
where she started at the beginning of
the week before she took the money out
so when people were like oh no the
billionaires oh no poor them oh no it's
like you do not understand
one
how diverse their portfolios and where
they have their money spread out okay
between different assets companies
whatever
and also i mean not to mention probably
tax havens in areas that nobody knows
about so they've got millions billions
uh just hidden away
and
when it comes to billionaires
they can't spend the money fast enough
you could she literally gave the money
away and then made the money back
like that's how insane it is to be that
rich right and she's one of the good
people she's one of people that are
actually like using using their wealth
for good right warren buffett's another
one obviously the gates are another one
like these are people who are who are
using their wealth to benefit society
and those in it but uh yeah when people
come out and like oh no what are we
gonna do oh no the oh the billionaires
it's like they're going to be they're
going to be fine they're going to be
very very fine
they're going to they're going to lay
down well they might not be they might
not be fine but they're not going to run
out of money right you know what and at
the end of the day after they lose it
they're going to lay down and they're
like billion dollars
silk thread count
and then they're going to wake up the
next morning
and someone's going to it's all over
again and then the money's back there
some some mate or someone's going to
come in take the sheets go burn them
because they're like we don't need to
use these and they put a brand new sheet
billion thread count back on the bed
and then every day it's just they're
just they just they can't burn money
fast enough
well i i say i say instead of them
burning let's just
just take it from them right i mean eat
the rice
whatever you want to do make sure make
sure people don't uh go bankrupt over a
medical bill that'd be a good idea right
maybe make sure maybe make sure kids are
educated and we have uh actual math
books in states you know instead of
banning them that would be i will i will
say this on the on the on the medical
bill thing i from personal experience i
once had a what ended up being i had a
stye on my eye
uh i went
to
the i went to the hospital because i
went to go get it checked out because
for a few days it just like kind of
stayed there and it was irritating it
was sore and like felt i was like oh
maybe this is maybe i don't know what
this is maybe this is really bad
i went to the hospital i left they had
put um
droplets in my eye to like help dilate
and to help look at what was there and
then in addition
they looked at um
uh just like if there were any foreign
objects or whatever and then they put
eye drops in and they said oh you know
what you should go and do warm
compresses
and go to go to walgreens the bill
literally the bill for just getting eye
drops in and tell me to go to walgreens
was 857
that's that's expensive advice to just
walk in get some eye drops and go to
walgreens so
it it was not pink eye it was a stye
regina reeves saying it was pink eye it
wasn't a big eye but i was afraid it was
but it actually wasn't it was just a sty
and they're like oh we just do warm
compresses and it'll eventually resolve
itself yeah well what going break we're
going bankrupt right
and no reason well but you should not
lose a paycheck over going to the
hospital well a lot of people uh doubt
that 850 dollars would make someone
bankrupt but it can in this country yeah
absolutely especially if you were living
in san francisco and you're like oh that
850 goes to my rent right right right
are part of it
everyone's yelling and screaming here in
the comments about marjorie taylor green
and i know the news about marjory taylor
green and we're going to talk about
marjory taylor green right now because
dark maga is still trending
and dark maga are terrorists which means
republicans are terrorists
and look who we have on the um on the uh
there's three amigos right the the three
uh main terrorists here um but dark maga
is still trending
um as everyone knows uh marjorie
taylor-green's case did you hear this
game that marjorie taylor's speaking of
of fascists and nazis marjorie taylor
green's a court case
to make sure that she can't run for
congress a federal judge says yes it can
advance
um and what their is that yesterday's
decision or today's i believe that was
yesterday's decision is that right yeah
yeah let's see here i've got the uh
robin sent me the um the link here let's
let's pull it up here we'll pull up the
the tweet
the tweety tweet um it is from john
breaking we just won a federal ruling in
the atlanta out in the in atlanta
allowing georgia voters to challenge
marjorie taylor greene as disqualified
under section 3 of the 14th amendment
the insurrection disqualification clause
this is the same clause that they're
trying to use for madison gothard right
now i just want to clarify this doesn't
mean that she could
potentially move to a new district right
and run right this means that she would
be disqualified
from running forever
or just in a district are you talking
are you asking me that question yeah do
you know that answer so so i do not know
that answer but i do think under section
3 of the 14th amendment um what this
does is keep her off the current ballot
um i don't know if it bans her from the
bow for good
from what i understand the only way to
technically ban someone for good from
from federal ballots
is that congress actually has to make
that make that um
make that sign that into law with a
piece of legislation and they have to
declare that which they have before um
and they probably will again if if we
get the breaking news right on the oath
keeper speaking of dark manga and nazis
um
let's go back to dark manga because i do
i do want to touch on that because i i
think this is important and relevant to
this topic
because literally what they're saying is
we are the baddies like they're saying
now yeah are visa buddies right well
they're not asking the question they're
saying no i know yeah like it's not a
question mark right but also
i mean they're i mean they're doubling
down right you look at you look at okay
it was make america great again right
again and then again and again again and
again and again right he's like done
again again again again again again i
think you did a few videos that made fun
of him right exactly and and and where
he where he openly says oh i could do
that to sell you more hats and i was
like yeah and it's like you guys are
going to sell us more hats you guys
are okay with it right
so in this instance right now
you've got dark magga right and dark
magga you think this group would be like
which they all say it's like it's some
it's there's not a uh there's not uh
it's a movement right and they said it's
not one clear
uh leader or owner of it it's just kind
of it's
it's like a a node of different people
and you look at this situation of dark
maga and you say one
you know
pretty ridiculous that you would call
yourselves dark mega
two your own you're you're you're really
like leaning into the name right and
dark side like the dark side from star
wars right well that's like that's like
the people who that's like the people
who are like oh you know yeah yeah we
want to be part of the empire and then
it's like you do realize that the empire
was bad right nice
you're saying that you're the empire
but you are but you're the rebellion
like you you're fighting for the empire
you're fighting for the bad guy right
you're fighting for the story for the
baddies they're the baddies
so
they literally stormed troop the capital
like that right no yeah they're like
which which there is news on the oath
keepers by the way speaking of that
speaking of that there is news on the
oath keepers um that that we have um
because the oath keepers it's found that
the oath keepers were actually in
communication with uh well at the time
was congressman uh ronnie jackson but
you may know him as dr ronnie jackson
the guy who stood up and had to
shamelessly lie about donald trump's
weight and height and his health yeah
it's really [ __ ] gross
but apparently
apparently the word is that um he was in
communication with stuart rhodes
directly and that he was asking for
protection
during the insurrection right the reason
why is because he had sensitive data
which i don't know if that was like
trump's actual height and weight or what
that you know i'm not sure exactly what
that sensitive data was but it appears
that he was he's full of [ __ ] yeah
physical is what ronnie jackson had
the what yeah the actual the actual the
real physical not the doctored physical
right uh but the right i figured it
might be a bottle of whiskey that he was
protecting too i don't know and you're
right well you know whenever we've seen
ronnie jackson it's on twitter or at the
bar really you know like he seems like
he's always drunk tweeting and you know
he's he's he's kind of a lush but i i
will say uh as much as ronnie jackson is
a bonehead
um
that that guy was was texting and asking
for protection now think about this for
a second
there is an insurrection happen there's
a violent insurrection happening or
there isn't right it can't be one or the
other ronnie jackson who is a
congressman who would say today that oh
those people at january 6 they were the
good guys right
he was asking for protection from those
people right right
from the oath keepers
and apparently the proud boys as well he
was in communication with them
these text messages just keep getting
deeper and deeper what i want to know
what i want to know
specifically about ronnie jackson and
his text that day
is was he seditiously sexting mark
meadows too like how many text messages
was mark meadows [ __ ] getting that
day dude i wanna look all i'm gonna say
is
mark meadows was quite the popular guy
all right
after the election around the election
uh
during the insurrection you know
anything with
action in it uh so
not to be confused with uh tucker
carlson's tanned erection right right
right yeah exactly um but what i will
say is like yeah that phone again that
phone is what every republican wants
hunter biden's laptop to be this thing
has touched so many people and whoa whoa
whoa whoa easy easy well look i'm not
i'm just saying you know i mean i say
seditiously sexting but i'm i'm being
hyperbolic are you do you think do you
think that the phone you don't think
that the phone just like touched some
people like without consent i guarantee
that phone touch people without grabbing
by the [ __ ] type stuff yeah mark
meadows phone became like donald trump
like i think very much that that phone
was by the [ __ ]
appropriately technically he's grabbing
mark bundles by the [ __ ] for sure um
you know it's biting him in the ass for
sure but here's here's the thing is that
there's no evidence that ronnie jackson
actually texts mark mattis we're making
all that [ __ ] up yeah but here's the
thing but
it's probably gonna be real
right that's what i was about to say
it's not it's it's so not [ __ ]
unplausible here in this scenario here
we are joking about mark meadows texting
four days from now two more and then
we're gonna find a tweet that goes out
with an official document from the jan
six committee from like uh liz cheney
and
she's gonna be like oh here is this
section where uh ronnie jackson asked
mark meadows how to get into the safe
room right like how do i get into the
bunker or like whatever it is and maybe
again i'm very curious what the details
of this sensitive data is again i would
imagine that it's actual trump's actual
height and weight as well right they're
like oh no then it's just gonna get out
they're gonna find out it's one number
it's just a bmi it could be it could be
the p tape too i'm just saying oh i'm
just saying this could be the beat tape
so ronnie jackson just keeps it close
he's like
well i mean you know if you're gonna
trust if you are a person you're gonna
trust someone wouldn't you trust the
doctor who lies about your physical with
the tape that you might yeah i guess so
yeah
i mean who knows it could be a ton of
stuff it could be that it could be the
actual events of hunter biden's laptop
i was gonna say the what ronnie jackson
had could be the actual play-by-play of
what happened when uh trump went to
um the hospital for covent okay well it
could be the notes it could be the notes
from the translator in the putin meeting
it could be those sensitive data i'm
just you know it's very weird that like
i
i don't know if it's uh
if these people like to inflict pain on
themselves
or
or they like to live
a risky life but know that it like never
plays out how they want in terms of like
some dumb ass reveals something about
what they did so when i look at them i'm
like do they just always carry around
this info this like stuff that could
incriminate them right they carry it
around and then they're just like i just
like to keep it close because it makes
me feel alive you know like but it's all
the incred like if somewhere to open up
the briefcase of data that ronnie
jackson had it's everything from uh
conversation with putin it's uh
verification and actual like
correspondence between putin and trump
saying that he wanted to
um rig the election it's uh it's
everything that has to do with the
p-tape with him getting covenant going
to the hospital late at night uh it's
what happened during the election in
2020 it could be a whole host of things
it's a whole thing it's it might be a
photo of him and stormy daniels and
their late night session it could be so
many different things
but all of them are just like oh he just
collects it as like like a serial killer
or sociopath would collect like trinkets
of things from their like victims he
just collects all the things that would
just like kill him right these are all
things that would incriminate himself
but he keeps him close i mean
technically i think the sensitive data
is this
you know and and maybe i'm just uh you
know way out in left field here
but when you do a physical on someone
when a doctor does a physical on someone
they generally they generally do a full
physical they check they check you know
the parts of their body their heart
their lungs
possibly if they have any stds or you
know
mike might do the old turn and cough
type thing to see if they have a hernia
you know check them for hernia right
yeah
so my guess is is that ronnie jackson
has the data of how small donald trump's
penis actually is and that is probably
the sensitive data that he was using to
try to gain protection and i would not
doubt it there's text messages from mark
meadows saying hey i don't want people
to have to find out
how small donald trump actually how much
of a man he is or isn't
so i need protection and then it might
be that we find out that he doesn't tan
his balls or what do you what i don't
know i don't know what's going on here
that that's that's that was weird yeah
you all of a sudden uh talking about
tanning balls you all said yeah balls
and ronnie jackson i found myself in a
doctor's office
he's listening someone is listening out
there i think that was weird
um so back to the um
the dark manga
because this is a newsweek article and
basically it seems like it's people who
want revenge
um that donald trump lost and that
donald trump is irrelevant and they're
really [ __ ] pissed off because it's
the nazis it's the alt-right they're
right their their feelings are hurt that
trump lost and continues to get made fun
of
this is like typical in cell behavior
in the basement writing their you know
their uh
their long
long you know manifesto where they say
dark magga is here to stay dark magga's
you know it's
really stupid [ __ ] yeah
well amy says here when you join dark
maga
you get a free hood
tiki torch and my bellow
it sounds like uh yeah like typically
when you join a company you get like the
swag that goes with it you're like oh
here's a keychain he's a shirt and
here's a water bottle they're like
straight up here's your hoodie on the
inside it's our manifesto
uh and it's about it's basically it's
mineconf and then they're also like uh
and when you sleep at night um here's my
pillow from uh
mike lindell and to get you to your home
from our you know nazi headquarters you
need a tiki torch
us u.s singers here usa singers here
says
uh dark manga is what happens when you
tan your testicles too much
you got them a little too dark maga
they're a little bit too dark
a little little burnt a little a little
crispy crisp crispy testies yeah look
which would make sense you know honestly
which would make sense why trump might
use the red light uh therapy
to tan his balls you know if you were to
say that it does increase testosterone
and make you larger
uh especially if you were to say that uh
you know what what stormy daniel said
was true which is like she's like oh
it's so small and it was just like it
was like toad from mario you know
that's what she said she said it looked
like toad from mario it looked like toad
it was that that well you know
it was just that megan
mushroom yeah maybe the sensitive data
might be jackson is just weird that he
would keep that with him but again like
i said like maybe he just like maybe he
took a polaroid i don't know what doctor
he's a director like maybe he's like a
masochist so he like likes to kill he's
like i like the pain of maybe being
found out just a possibility right
scary larry says here dark magan quotes
as if there's some other light-hearted
happy fun manga no it's all the same
pro-fascism pro-authoritarianism
pro-white nationalism pro-or
anti-democracy excuse me
the point here is is that larry's making
is that this is the same people that
showed up in charlottesville
these are the same people who are
marching in the streets as patriot front
who used to be vanguard this is the same
people who who went down the florida who
hung
let's go brandon uh banners over the the
overpass
with the with the swastikas on them
they're the let's go brandon nazis right
and they have to keep branding and the
reason why is because they're really
[ __ ] boneheaded and they can't stop
doing bone-headed [ __ ] and we always
point it out
always point it out like for instance
when they decided that they wanted to
marry children and it was a good idea to
pass a law in tennessee to do that and
everyone's like what in the actual [ __ ]
are you talking about right and the
entire country went no you cannot do
that and they changed it they changed it
that's why they're changing their name
and the reason why they're changing
their name is just like you said they
want to make it sound like it's revenge
it's revenge uh mayo one of our
favorites here says dark manga is what
trump calls his dirty diapers
oh was it was it a light maga or a dark
maga grandpa poopy pants i it it
when i think of when i think of like
light maga dark maga uh type of stuff it
makes me think of
either a beer or a coffee like really
what how do you like you know for coffee
like how do you like your roast yeah
like a dark are you like a light right
how do you like your you like a heavy
like a a dark magga or do you like a
light magga you know like mac a light
you know
uh uh jen says here dark maga like this
isn't
like it isn't already dark enough like
this is this has been manga the whole
time
they only have one timeline and that
timeline is [ __ ] dark right well i
mean right they've always been the bad
guy they've always been the evil empire
they just have to keep well i mean even
in the star wars movie you know they
rebrand the empire right you know like
we're gonna keep similar colors but
we're still pretty bad right we're still
the baddies we're still the baddies um
you you gotta head out here in just a
second um i think there was one more
topic that i wanted to ask you about
um
oh nate silver that's i think we need to
talk about the other papers
silver
um his great take on the um he says this
morning oh here's your take yeah g whiz
for a guy that claims to be smart nate
silver sure is dumb according silver
coved just magically appeared around the
world no help to people traveling just
poof
um he really is forgetting again that
that this is also the guy that i'm sure
if you looked up tweets you would find
the ones where he talks about getting
into closed spaces and wearing masks in
the early like august 2020
so
you know i i will say i've said it
before and i'll say it again kovid
really [ __ ] with people's heads okay
right they it changed the way that they
looked at reality it changed the way
that they looked at politics uh society
other people and and how they approach
it and unfortunately
it did [ __ ] with their heads where
whether it was coveted itself or the you
know just the the situation of being in
a pandemic
they
just threw everything out of the [ __ ]
window it was like all sense of logic
and reasoning went right out we don't
want to trust doctors the doctors we do
want to trust aren't actually board
certified or are some crazy
uh alien dna sperm
uh you know satan uh type of uh uh of um
beliefs right like these are the people
that's also the one that trump was like
oh yeah she's got some good stuff dr
amanda are they still are these the same
aliens that are gonna bring jfk junior
back down so he can run retro it might
be i don't know you know they they probe
to reveal jk junior and they probe to
you know maybe
give you the vaccine i don't really just
saying what you're saying i know man
it's a q a world we're just living in it
hey just asking questions okay right
more bone-headed about nate silver's
tweet because i think his his tweet's
kind of boneheaded right um and if you
go read my tweet and basically i'm like
because he says the average american
spends like five hours uh per year on a
plane i said uh the average american
spends like five seconds a year
listening to nate silver um is what i
said but
more than that it's the decision from
the judge that is actually really
[ __ ] boneheaded now right you can
disagree and argue the whole [ __ ] but
the context of who the judge is really
matters well that is true but here's the
the one [ __ ] sentence that the judge
has in there is she's like well the only
thing that a mask does is catch the the
droplets with the with the with the
corona virus in it the particles in it
that way well yeah that's the whole [ __ ]
the whole [ __ ] point is for the mass
to catch the disease in the mass so it
doesn't spread to someone else like you
just said what the mask does they do
that though they run right into the
[ __ ] point head first every time
they're like so in summation uh the mask
actually does work right but
we're not gonna require it yeah so mate
silver over here is like oh well you
know uh the margin or whatever he said
wow yeah he's basically he's basically
saying he's basically saying if a few
people get sick it's not going to make
an overall difference right which on and
that's how it all [ __ ] started does
right exactly a few people got sick they
traveled right now whether you want to
debate it was on the plane or not but
the fact that you were going into a
highly concentrated pact
i i i like margie here's in summation
that you're really you're really digging
a game there margie you're becoming one
of my favorite yeah i just i just felt
like that would be what she would say
she would be like in summation in
summation um is that is it that you're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're bitching
that would benjamin he probably like
ergo you know
here we go doesn't even wear glasses so
i just do this like for how do you know
he might wear glasses or glasses
yeah he could he could have uh anyway
anyway what i'm saying here is nate
silver like he goes oh a few people here
and there doesn't really matter in the
grand scheme of things however that same
type of thinking of like oh well a few
people here and there well that's how it
all started right you look at it and you
say well only a few people had covid
right wasn't a big deal well
it's it's not like for it's not like
life or death or something like that
right there's only there was only a
couple people that died somebody coughed
somebody sneezed somebody breathed
somebody spoke
droplets go somewhere that person gets
it that person goes to see family
it's like um if anyone out there who's
listening or watching has seen
um
rise of the planet of the apes right at
the at the end of the movie what ends up
happening is the guy who works at the
clinic gets he gets a
uh um
like a dosage of the the
the treatment that they were giving the
the chimpanzees right he gets sick
because it's not meant for humans that
guy goes to uh
james franco's house coughs on the
neighbor that neighbor's a pilot at the
end of the movie
that neighbor
goes
and travels so he goes to the airport
and then you see this whole thing spread
and it's literally a a representation of
what happened
well i mean here's the thing
the thing that nate silver and even this
judge
um
is is really
and i think americans or anyone who is
either anti-massacre pro basket whatever
you want to say i think the one thing
that we're discounting here is the judge
said some really stupid [ __ ] in this
decision but if you're going to make a
case like if you're really going to make
a case for not having mask on public
transportation which honestly the case
should be
why is it such a big deal if we do it
for a little bit longer right number one
it's not it's not affecting anyone
negatively if we have another six months
or a year's worth of data on the vaccine
because i think that's the actual best
case to make to not have a mask on like
that is the best case to be made is that
the vaccine has proven to be very
effective it has been proven to be very
effective in that it you will not you
will not pass away and you will not be
hospitalized now there are people out
there who still do get sick and still
get hospitalized and some die right even
with the vaccine but those are the ones
on the far margin so that is truly the
argument to be made this judge did not
make the vaccine argument and the reason
why is because the judge is anti-mask
she's anti-vaccine because the context
that you were talking about earlier is
not only is she a trump appointed judge
she's one of the ones that they said
she's not qualified to be a federal
judge 33 and they're you know i think
there's like 22 people that have ever
that have been uh
or of of the people that have been
nominated and appointed to a lifetime
federal judge federal judge position 22
have been deemed as not qualified
and
she was one of them right and it should
be notice no surprise to anyone that
somebody like there's a theme going on
here like call me crazy but there's a
theme
that when trump appoints someone put
someone in a cabinet position put
someone on a federal position put
someone or nominate someone for anything
else or even says i endorse this person
like dr oz who's [ __ ] a quack doctor
these people are not qualified
they are
terrible people who don't know what
they're doing and they're given high
ranking positions that can impact the
lives or or or policies of many people
and as a result
especially a federal lifetime position
you are now
and not only that but also one who's 33
years old for a lifetime you're talking
about setting rules and precedence up
by the judge for years to come that will
impact the lives of
tons and tons of people
and so again there's a theme call me
crazy but it seems like trump appoints
nominates or endorses people who are
just not qualified and [ __ ] over
everyone else
that's what it is
well i i want to say one more thing
before you jump because margie and she
makes a a point here one judge shouldn't
have the power to affect every single
chavral and that's margie as much as
that may not be true or good or bad um
the judge and i think that's the point
gabe's trying to make if you are a
qualified judge you should be able to
make decisions that affect every single
traveler but make it for the good of
every single traveler not for the bad of
every single driver i think that's the
point and that's why it's so important
that we keep the messaging up we
participate in our democracy we beat
pro-democracy for this 2020 mid 2022
midterm is so not to elect morons like
dr oz or the the guy who loves america's
hitler jd vance which i'm going to show
a video about that when we come back
gabe thanks for joining us today we'll
see you tomorrow and stick around
everyone we'll be right back with the jd
vance loves hitler video we'll be right
back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
gabe sanchez
with the long rants my voice is is
rested today
how about we finish off the last 20
minutes with some rants about dark manga
and the nazis that are dark manga and
you know
it's not surprising that these people
are saying the quiet part out loud
it really isn't um amanda points out
something here she says trump doesn't
care if they're qualified he's a fascist
loyalty is the only qualification and
you're right amanda you're right because
that's what fascists want they want
loyalty to their regime
speaking of loyalty to their regime i
don't know if you guys have seen uh or
heard of jd vance jd vance is the guy
who made him who wrote a book and made a
movie about
country people becoming elites and
leaving behind their country and their
their their country roots their redneck
roots and becoming elites now he's a
he's a traitor to
his uh his culture i guess you would say
but jd vance loves hitler he's in love
with hitler america's hitler that is
jd vance has been um
been discovered that he text his
roommate
in 2016 when donald trump was running he
called donald trump at the time
america's hitler
jd vance the guy running for senate in
ohio
who just received america's hitler's
endorsement
and this is how hitler works i think
this is how it works folks like
jd vance
isn't wrong about america's hitler
trump that is being america's hitler not
wrong
and it is evident in jd vance himself
like he proves it outright
that the fascist regime
the fascist that is donald trump
america's hitler that is donald trump
even though he's a nin kapoor nazi cause
let's face it he is a ninja boop nazi
the whole point is is that when you need
to
get power yourself or maintain your own
power
you will capitulate to the regime you
will capitulate to fascism
so yeah jd
he is america's hitler now listen to
what jd said
on steve bannon's traitor tv st speaking
of [ __ ] dark manga and nazis
jd vance appears on steve bannon's
trader tv here
but listen to the sound
of jd vance
how much he loves america's hitler let's
listen
make the cage right now again a couple
of minutes make the case to make trump
to say this is my guy because i agree
with trump he's certainly the best
president of my lifetime he was a
fighter for people that i care about
more than any politician in the in in
this country in in 30 40 years i'm on
the team as the president said jd gets
it i'm actually going to stand for the
president make
so basically jd vance is saying i love
the president i love trump trump's my
guy and trump loves me because i love
him it's exactly what ma amanda is
saying
is that it has nothing to do with
qualifications jd vance may not even be
qualified to be dog catcher but he
definitely is loyal to america's hitler
and the reason why is because jd vance
loves fascism that's the secret here
folks
trump is not the [ __ ] problem trump
is the symptom
dark manga
fascism in our country people people
greedy for for american authoritarianism
that's the problem folks
that's the problem
it's american this this longing for
american authoritarianism
that is our problem trump is just the
symptom
trump is just the symptom hell hitler
was a symptom in nazi germany
the disease the disease was their
longing for authoritarianism
for someone to wave a magic wand and to
fix all their problems
and that's just not the way it works in
society
not everyone's problems are fixed with
one swing of the wand
now jd vance believes that because jd
vance believes he's an elite
and elites typically believe
that when the magic wand is waved it is
waved in their favor
just like steve bannon and donald trump
and all the other sycophants
that have continued on this scourge for
authoritarianism
so jd vance suckles at the teat
of america's hitler
and this is dark manga this is it right
in front of you and the reason why it's
dark maga is because jd vance
is the dog and dark magga is the tail
and the tail is wagging the dog
jd vance is not capitulating to donald
trump
because he thinks hitler good
he doesn't care if hitler's good or not
he doesn't care if hitler's good for you
or not he doesn't care if there's
equality he doesn't care if there's
equity he's a rich white elite
he made it he made it out of being a
redneck
he made it he's now an elite he ain't
got to worry about all that [ __ ]
mj said he's got eyeliner on he probably
has to worry about his eyeliner he might
have to
i don't know you know maybe he's wearing
makeup maybe he's not and maybe that's
you know maybe what he's uh showing off
for trump here is
um his makeup skills i mean trump
requires makeup skills that's why i
never figured out why trump likes bannon
jesus christ this guy [ __ ]
you couldn't put enough makeup on this
[ __ ]
but dark manga
the alt-right
the fascists in this country the white
supremacists the nazis
the nazis in this
country are the tail that are wagging
the dog
and they want authoritarianism they want
it bad
because they know what authoritarian
brings
authoritarianism brings them the ability
to take away consent from you about your
children
take away your consent
they know what it will do is give them
the ability to tear down the public
education system
so that way they can indoctrinate
children into their way of being and
they can also marry them that's what
they want to do they want to marry
children they don't want children to be
educated enough not to know not to marry
them i mean what i mean by that is old
white men want to marry little girls
they also don't want you to be smart
enough to know about equality and equity
or have the brains enough to know
that
gender is not sexualized they don't want
you to know that gender has nothing to
do with sexuality they don't want you to
know that
they don't even want you to do math in
florida they're like math [ __ ] math
we're banning all math books [ __ ] math
we're not doing that
we're for division just not long
division
that's dark maga
that's where we're at folks
and it's going to continue
it's going to continue it's not going to
stop it's not like dark maga is the last
stop in american authoritarianism
it's not
it's not the last stop
they're gonna rebrand dark manga is the
alt-right the the [ __ ] tiki torch
[ __ ] that showed up at
charlottesville that's dark maga
that's dark magga it's the same
[ __ ]
it ain't like people woke up this
morning and decided well we're dark maga
now instead of the alt-right we're not
trump supporters anymore we're dark
manga
and they're looking for revenge and the
revenge they're looking for is to
revenge on our democracy because they
really are pissed off that they weren't
able to tear down our democracy on
january 6. they're really [ __ ] pissed
about it they weren't able to overthrow
our constitution they're so upset about
it that they're still
still trying to overturn elections
inside of states our vote
trying to overturn and overthrow our
vote it's ours not theirs
joe biden is not
is not the united states president he's
our president
we elected him just like we elected
barack obama
we elected donald trump we elected
george w bush as much as people don't
like it we did that and we did it under
our election system
the same same way we've been doing it
for for several several decades under
our election system
with the primary process
the general election process and we have
an election coming up
the 2022 midterms and it's up to us the
pro-democracy people to make sure that
american
authoritarianism does not take control
in this country and i'm not just talking
about in the united states house of
congress
i'm talking about in the senate i'm
talking about in the state governorships
i'm talking about in the state
legislators your county commissions
your city councils your school boards
this is all important the dark maga the
alt-right the ninja poop nazis
as they are do not take over control
and do not push american
authoritarianism we can not let
authoritarianism
take hold in this country
we must
not
let
authoritarianism take control of our
country and the way we do that is to be
pro-democracy all the time everywhere
all the time everywhere we have to have
strategic outrage we have to have our
messaging together
that's important and they're giving us
all the messaging we need because folks
the generic ballot
the people out there who don't pay
attention to politics but are going to
go vote against something we have to
give them something to vote against
we must
our messaging is important
we can't just say go vote because
democrats want to give you this
democrats want to give you that
look republicans the change that is
coming with republicans
you can see it all around you
they want to ban math books they want to
marry your children they want to take
women's bodily autonomy away
so much so that they don't have liberty
the women's vote is next hec they're
trying to stop black people from voting
they're stopping they're stopping
groceries from coming into our country
to damage joe biden in the next election
greg abbott is stopping groceries from
coming in our country think about that
for a second
you don't think that's a good way for
texas
that you want that's the change
that texas wants
is to make sure that groceries get on
their shelves because we literally have
empty shelves abbott down in texas
trying to stop groceries from coming in
our country
yes he turned his policy around
but
the [ __ ] republican kidnappers in
tennessee turned their policy around
after they told us yeah i want to marry
a 14 year old girl
that's what they said
by not having an age limit in their law
they're trying to use discrimination
against lgbtq community
to pass a law to where they can marry
children and they're like oh wait you
caught us being pedophiles well we're
not pedophiles
yes you are
greg abbott's like oh you caught me
you know
stopping groceries at the border
groceries that texas
definitely need to eat
and for grocery store shelves to be full
and he tuck tailed and run no
he still owns that just because a
republican decides not to do something
doesn't mean they won't do it again you
think greg abbott
won't try to won't try to hurt texans
because he thinks it's politically good
for him
come on now he's gonna do it over and
over he did it with the power grid he
did it with groceries
you don't think that republicans these
pedocons all around the country who are
who are trying to sexualize your kid's
gender and who are trying to marry your
[ __ ] children
trying to take away a age limit on
marrying children
you think they're just gonna stop
wanting to marry children just because
they took it out of this bill
what about the next bill that's all
they're [ __ ] focused on they can't
focus on anything else but taking
people's liberty away from them and you
don't think they'll come for you these
are the people you want in charge of
your economy
these are the people you want in charge
of your children's education the ones
who want to marry your kids
you want to rely on these people
to be in charge of your gas prices
the people who are who are making sure
to stop groceries from being on the
grocery store shelves that's who you
want in charge of gas prices the
republicans the kid diddlers the petal
cons the gqp dark magda the ninka poop
nazis that's who you want in charge of
our economy that's who you want in
charge of our children's education
that's who you want in charge of our
health care
those folks
that's the messaging
next time you're talking to someone
about education it doesn't matter where
it's at it doesn't even matter the
context
it doesn't matter you ask them the
question
did you hear that florida is trying to
ban math
tony that's just hyperbolic
no it's not
they're trying to ban 54 arithmetic
books in florida
they do not want your kids to learn math
it has something to do with crt and it's
a totally different crt like it's a
whole nother phrase that has the letter
crt
but it doesn't matter even ron desantis
is saying oh well common core math is
too hard for parents to to help their
kids with their homework
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] so just because the
current generation is dumber
and can't [ __ ]
understand common core math then we
shouldn't make sure the next generation
understands it get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] that's the dumbest
[ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever heard of in my
life
they want to undo public education folks
they want to undo public education the
whole thing
kindergarten through 12th grade they
want to get rid of it
they want to tear the entire education
system apart
they don't want your kids to be educated
they don't want them to be well they do
but it's called indoctrination
they want to put them in re-education
camps
they want to make sure that they're
diluted the same way that they're
diluted
to authoritarianism
how do you think it happened to nazi
germany
do you think they just continued on with
the public school system that school
system that they had in nazi germany you
think that's what they did no they tore
it down they tore it all apart
steve bannon on trader tv says it every
[ __ ] day it's their plan
their plan is to take over government so
they can tear down all of our
institutions inside of our democracy
our safety net our public education
system health care
government your freedom and liberty they
want to tear it apart
it's the only way they feel like they
survive
and by they
i mean the oppressors
the ningapoop nazis
because they want to oppress your rights
because they think it's their freedom to
oppress your rights because they're
fascist
we strive for liberty in this country
that is our goal life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness but
liberty is our goal and the vehicle that
gets us to liberty is our rights and our
freedoms and it's not always perfect
folks democracy is not perfect and it's
difficult it democracy is a [ __ ]
because not everyone is happy all the
time
it's just not how it happens with
democracy it's actually the model that's
how you progress and you get better as
time goes on
because you don't have one person
with authoritarianism telling you what
to do
we get to decide with our liberty but
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty
and when you are taking away the freedom
and the right for people to know the
truth
and to be educated
to have a human right that is health
care and medical attention
to make sure that people have
have the liberty of the autonomy of
their own bodies and to make the choices
that they want to make rather it's about
who they love
who they want to be with how many kids
they want to have whether they want
their kids to go to public school or not
those are the choices that are afforded
to us
that give us our liberty in this country
and make us a democracy no matter what
they say we're not democracy we're
republic we're republic
a republic is a democracy you dumb
[ __ ]
so know this
know this here on the tony michaels
podcast every single weekday monday
through friday we will continue to pound
the message for two hours every single
day yeah sometimes we we get silly and
talk about tacos like we did today
but it's so you pay attention to that
pro-democracy message
because that's what we have to carry
that's where we have to go we have to
win this election and yes 2022 is the
most important election because it's the
next one
and then the one after that 2024 is the
most important election because it is
the next one that's how democracy works
that's how we get better that's how we
progress
that's how we afford more people more
liberty and we achieve more equity more
equality and that's what they're scared
of folks
they're scared of people having equity
they're scared of people having equality
they're scared that they don't have the
freedom to oppress our rights
they feel like it's their white
privilege to oppress our rights
people that look like me
a white dude
who sound like me a white dude want to
oppress your rights
i'm here to fight for him every single
day monday through friday keep listening
keep we'll keep pounding the microphone
every single day you guys go out there
repeat the messaging tell your neighbors
tell your friends right here on youtube
twitter twitch and now from the minus
touch facebook page noon eastern 11
central nine pacific
and until tomorrow until hump day which
is tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking